SHOT, SAVE, REBOUND, STICK LIFT
D AN
QUICK, AND NOW ADRIAN KEMPE
TURNS TO THE NET, AND D AND
TREVOR MOO HERE  HEAD TO THE
NET.T. OFF
DUNCAN KEITH'S STICK, GETS BY
SUBMIT.
THIS
TALKING ABOUT THE
ANDERSON.
LEAVES THE PUCK FOR HYMAN,
HE'LL L GAME FOUR
AND THE WAY THE KINGS ARE GOING
RIGHT NOW, THAT UP
WITH IT, AND THIS ONE SNEAKS
UNDER AND
DRAISAITL TO PROVIDE ALL OF THE
LOOK AT DANAUL YEARS NOW FOR
LEON.
FOUR OILERS LAUGHTER ] KANE FOR
ON THE MOVE WITHOSES HIS
GLOVE HERE ANDOULD BE A TOUGH T
NET.
KINGS IN THE FIRST ROUND BACK
IN 2003,3, PICK IT UP.
KINGS IN THE MIDST OF A CHANCKE
OFF HIS SKATE, AND EDMONTON
STOP FOR THE KINGS GOALTENDE NO
MOMOTO FIND THAT,
AND HANG ON.  HE FINDS AN OPENI
IN.
>> THIS IS UNDER REVIEW AT THIS
AND D
HANDS IT TO HIM.
BROWN FOR GRUNDSTROM.
THAT GOAL WAS HIS FIRST,
>> WELL, THE KINGS ALL NIGHT AS